[Music]
i want to talk about
positivity or hear you talk about
positivity
because for instance i was i was reading
a piece in variety
that seemed to me to indicate that you
are a master of managing
energy and avoiding energy leaks
and for instance the decision to
allow your children to get to know your
uh their grandfather your father
the quote that stuck out to me was it
takes too much time and energy to keep
hate alive
and for those people who don't know i
mean your father was an addict
you've you've spoken about him publicly
before a contentious relationship
uh how have you developed that
positivity
was that uh mostly from your mom uh how
do you think about that
well when you when you come from the
bottom
yeah and you work your way
up to when you work your way up to the
place that some people refer to as the
top
i mean what what do i have to be angry
about
what do i have to really [ __ ] and
complain about
and harpoon you know what i mean like i
i
i really do come from nothing
i'm uh i'm a part of a very small
percentage
so and understanding that and knowing
that
the things that are supposed to act as
triggers the things that are supposed to
be
life-changing threatening you know
altering
um are just lessons
it's just education it's it's
stories for lack of a better word you
know
you got an amazing story under your belt
and
i don't choose to stay in one particular
paragraph uh of my story
it's a long story and you know the life
is as long as
of course we are all given the
the chance for it to be uh because
that's something that we have no control
we only try to
enhance the opportunity of longevity
or success we don't have no control you
can walk outside
something could happen boom and that's
it so
i just have a realistic approach and
understanding to that
i come from nothing i got something
i'm appreciative of my something i don't
look at this something as if i'm
supposed to have it
because that's not how it works i'm very
fortunate and blessed too
it could all go away if it did and i had
to start all over again
that's life i don't harp on it
i don't [ __ ] and complain about the
things that i can't change
and the things that you can change
why spend time bitching if you're gonna
change it yeah you know what i mean
so when you when you look at for example
a relationship
uh with me and my father did my father
[ __ ] up
yeah uh did my father
get himself clean and straight yeah
does my father feel bad about some of
the stuff that he did yeah
could you still be angry at the lack of
parenting that was done or the time that
was spent yeah
but why it doesn't it doesn't change it
it doesn't change anything that happened
it doesn't it doesn't make it
right you know what i mean like you
don't that that anger that you're
that you're giving off into that it's
not going to change
these things so that's energy that i
feel like
i can put into something else that's
energy that i feel like
i can get a lot more use out of that
energy that would have been negative
by finding a way to say you know what i
do forgive you and i mean that
and that life now hopefully is better
for us if it's not i know that it's not
because of me
i don't like putting myself in a
position to easily be affected
you know i think life is too short it's
it's too
short and if you just spend time being
affected
all the [ __ ] time those are tough
days man
if you're bothered all the time
there's a lot of [ __ ] to be bothered
about today you can be bothered by
a lot of [ __ ] if you're the person
that's
really bothered then how how pleasant
are you to be around
yeah if there's just so much anger
and and so much negative energy
i i just choose the opposite direct and
approach and i mean
that doesn't make me perfect i'm nowhere
near perfect
i don't [ __ ] up i don't did stupid
[ __ ] and
i've apologized and if i can be uh
you know those apologies can be accepted
then great it's
fantastic if they can't well i can't do
anything about that i can't put any more
energy
into the things that i've tried to do or
make right if you choose to still feel a
certain way
god bless you i'm going to keep living
that's my attitude
you